[Music]
well it's not that the definition of
infinity that somewhere some if there is
really an infinity there is not only a
you and and I but there's a unit I and
everybody else we've ever met and all
the exact events in the exact same order
have gone down an infinite number of
times including this conversation okay
except except um there is I don't how
many people know this but often it's
mind-blowing when you learn that some
infinities are bigger than others Joe
Rogan just leaned two feet away from the
microphone
not all infinities are the same size but
if it's infinity then it's infinity whoa
what is well okay
don't you remember when you were kid
what's the biggest number you know a
million was a million and one right yeah
how about a billion was a billion and
one who's an annoying kid always added
one two okay how about infinity well
infinity and one right yeah well turns
out infinity 1 and if any are the same
number okay so here's a so for example
the number of of counting numbers so 1 2
3 up to infinity ok right the numbers
you would use to count things that's
infinite the number of irrational
numbers so the numbers that you cannot
represent as a fraction okay that
there's more there more of those than
there are counting numbers well by far
so these are orders of infinity then
there are more there are more
transcendental numbers then there are
irrational numbers what's a
transcendental number that's a number
that you'll never find as a solution to
to an algebraic equation so pi is a
transcendental number b is a transfer
these are these are magic numbers that
show up in mathematics and there's turns
out there's like an even bigger infinity
of those than there is of these other
two classes of numbers and they use the
the the the hebrew letter LS in in
ranking so LS 1 LF 2 LF 3 LF o think
there
five levels of infinity so my point is
just because there's infinite universes
to me doesn't mean there's infinite
conversations that have happened and I'd
want to really explore the depths of
infinities before I say and agree with
you that this conversation has happened
a million you know an infinite number of
times in just this way except you have a
different engineers sitting next to us
or and an infinite number of times where
it's been Jamie - right yeah the
integration problem that's the argument
that's that's given but I think that we
there's some nested infinities in there
that deserve some explanation
my favorite grain is not handling as
well that's fine as I said as I say in
the in the in the epigraph of the book
look it's not available yet but I have a
copy
haha astrophysicists four people in a
hurry astrophysics four people in a
hurry but you can say a benefit for
people who take them over their house
hey what do they say sorry astrophysics
for people in a hurry yes a quick you
say because you're no hurry so the
effort the epic the epigram on that is
the universe is under no obligation to
make sense to you that that's ration and
I've time 2004 and so it makes sense to
you that the universe is under no
obligation to make sense so it's okay if
your brain hurts when I say there's a
ranking of infinities but but you
shouldn't say that doesn't make sense
therefore it is not true I definitely
wouldn't say that but what what confuses
me is the word infinity because I had
always taken the word infinity to mean
something that has no end so how can
something that has no end be larger than
something else so the way they do that
mathematically the way to demonstrate
that mathematically is used you map one
item in the set of this infinity to
corresponding items in a set of the
other infinity so you do this so you
take the 1 and your map it to like the
first transcendental number say 2 2 to
the second you just keep doing this and
when you do that mathematically what you
find that 1 infinity outstrips the other
infinity Wow
and then you're left with more with more
numbers so that shows you that you have
a bigger infinity
[Music]